relationships and Disney Princess movies
have certainly come a long way since the
days of just waiting for a prince to
arrive discover more about the evolution
of Disney's most romantic couples and if
you're new to our channel hit the red
button down below to subscribe now White
and the prince
snow white and the friends are the first
in Disney's long line of human couples
and it's love at first sight they meet
when snow white sings at the wishing
well and the Prince surprises her by
joining in and they don't see each other
again until the Prince wakes her up with
a kiss they have to overcome the Evil
Queen's jealousy and her poisoned Apple
their love story in 1937 Snow White and
Seven Dwarfs it's typical of the classic
era of Disney Princess movies it was all
about the woman waiting for a prince to
rescue her fancy carbanion Princess
Aurora and Prince Philip although they
first meet when a young prince duelist
attends baby princess Aurora's
christening their first romantic meeting
is similar to tell white in the princess
Aurora's singing about her dream men and
lo and behold he surprises her by
joining in again it's love at first
sight and again they don't meet until he
wakes her up from the sleeping death
spell cast by a lower-risk woman this
time it's Maleficent it can be trolled
since first so it is like fate Sookie's
idea of romantic love in 1959 Sleeping
Beauty is much the same as in 1937 Ariel
and Prince Eric there was a 30 year wait
for the Little Mermaid and with that
change in time came a change in romantic
story the 1989 movie was the first to
Disney's Renaissance era with more
progressive and independent protagonists
in his Ariel who starts off as the
rescuer she first meets Prince Erik when
she saved him from John the destroyer
ship they have to overcome their
difference in safety then they have to
battle
Ursula which is Eric's time to be the
rescuer and they also have to convince
Ariel spotter that humans and mermaids
can be friends Belle and scenes in 1991
Beauty and the Beast
Belle also has to overcome a difference
in species when she falls for beasts
like Ariel Belle is more independent
than her predecessors but still yearns
for a love story and she finds it in the
unlikeliest of places she first meets
beast when she saves her father from his
dungeon it's a bad first impression
class they grow close as they spend more
time together
these softens and Galvin's appear
prejudiced when guests on attack this is
the one who's the rescuer those love
breaks the curse and turns back in
screams Adam Prentiss Jasmine in Aladdin
in previous films the male love interest
is a prince but 1992's
Aladdin breaks with tradition by having
a princess fall in love with the street
boy jasmine needs Aladdin in the market
when he saves the disguised princess
from a threat new stallholder they share
a connection but they're different in
class hands in the way as does
power-hungry villain Jafar the law says
she must marry royalty but Jasmine wants
to marry for love
Aladdin pretends to be a prince fearing
he's not good enough but she prefers the
real version and her father allows them
to marry this era film shows couples
overcoming obstacles created by society
rather than an individual Pocahontas and
John Smith in the 1995 movie Pocahontas
particular character first meets John
Smith when she secretly follows him as
he portal and he's come to colonize she
teaches him about nature and they fall
in love they must overcome their
preconceptions about each other and the
violence their groups are planning
Pocahontas saves John from execution but
he must return to England for medical
help unusually if this disney love story
doesn't have a happy ending Mulan and
Shang like jasmine and Aladdin Ron and
Shankar Smith when one subscribes in
1998 Mulan but move on pretends to be a
man much longer than jazz in place of
peasants Mulan and Shang become toast
friends as they train together in the
army
she even saves his life but once a true
gender is revealed their relationship
falters it's clear Shang still cares as
the ensure she isn't executed the story
doesn't end in marriage but with the
whole 15 of reconciliation Tiana and
Prince Naveen Tiana enemies love story
needs to take place in amphibian formed
in 2009 of Princess and the Frog Naveen
asked Tiana to kiss him to break to do
the spell that made from the Frog but a
pan isn't a princess she turns into a
frog too they spend a lot of time
bickering as they try to become new ones
horn but their love grows and they help
each other and when they marry as frogs
their case transforms them proving love
is more important than money or
Rapunzel and Flynn Rapunzel and Flynn
Rider get off to a rocky start in the
2010 movie Tangled named Wayne for
hitting him with a frying pan but they
open up to each other and see Flynn
realizes there's more to life than money
this movie returns to the classic
obstacle being a villainous woman
meaning Mother Gothel but Flynn Cruise
is loved by cutting Rapunzel's hair and
then she saves him with her magical
peers they have a more equal
relationship than urban or Disney couple
anna and kristoff unusual for a Disney
Princess film the main relationship
focus and frozen is a love between two
sisters but the 2013 movie also involved
a love interest
- in fact and it was duped by Prince
Hans but eventually found true love with
Kristoff it quite a departure from the
classic era where the good guy was
always the royal and where the
relationship was love at first sight and
where the princess waits passively for
the Prince to save the day these new
Disney coupled work together on their
adventures the Disney love story has
evolved to show more equality which is
your favorite Disney couple let us know
in the comments below and give our video
a big thumbs up